Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. This is my full video
for the boys
Gen V Episode 5
There are a bunch of Easter Eggs
and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
careful for spoilers
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, and work
our way through, shot by shot
Talking about Easter eggs
wtf moments. There was a lot of hardcore
puppet action
in this episode in a lot of degeneracy
some of the stuff they get down to in
this episode would make homelander blush.
the episode title is
Welcome to the Monster Club,
it is meant to be a reference
to all the kids, like not just Cate
because they out her as the monster
who has been wiping their minds is behind
this working with Vought this whole time.
the idea is that they all feel
like monsters or they have done monstrous
things.
The whole thing in the boys universe,
like one of the big twist,
the entire series, like the main series
too, is that there is no absolute good
or absolute evil in the boys universe,
like nobody's truly bad or truly good.
Everybody does really terrible stuff.
best example that is butcher like he's
meant to be just as bad as Homelander,
but in a completely different direction,
in a completely different way.
the actual episode begins
directly in the aftermath of
Sam's attack on Doctor
Ricardo's in their Misery blackout.
For a couple of days They were active.
But nobody remembers anything
since the events of Sam's attack.
And they don't remember
anything related to Sam at all.
They don't even remember that he exists.
they finally confirmed that it was Cate
who was behind that behind
all the mind wiping.
I think we all suspected
that she was going to betray them
at some point during the season early on,
she hated really weird, standoffish
to the rest of the Scooby Gang.
And like, last week in episode four,
she flat out kept reminding Andre
that the others did not matter
and not to get mixed up with them
now we know that's because she was working
for the dean in Vought this whole time.
He was trying to keep Andre
from getting killed or worse,
like she still cares about Andre,
even though
she's doing all these terrible things.
So she's trying to protect him
or she thinks he's trying to protect him
because when things become
too much of a problem for bot,
like if a superhero gets too out of line,
Vought will either have them killed
or they're too powerful to be killed.
they'll put them in cryo storage
like Soldier Boy Jensen Ackles character.
they would have done the same thing
to Stormfront after season two, like Stay
and Edgar would have put her in cryo
if he needed to,
if she hadn't have lost her arms and legs
and basically gave like Stormfront
allowed them to put her in that bed
in Homelander's apartment.
she kind of gave up
after the events of season two,
They also finally answered the question
about what Vought
was really using the Woods underground lab
for this whole time.
So Dr.
Cardoso reveals that he was perfecting
a virus that would allow Vought to control
all compound V's superheroes,
which would include people like Homelander
in other ultra powerful ones.
so this is actually really huge.
I think this is where we get to the boys
Season four
because it's been Stan Edgar's big problem
this whole time
that he's been working for Vought
since he was a young man.
He was never able to fully solve
controlling superheroes
because they always caused
so much collateral damage.
he figured out how to perfect the compound
v formula
over time like refining it over time
since Soulja Boy.
So he made more powerful superheroes.
Like that's where Homelander came from.
he figured out
how to make money off of superheroes
kind of in the Disney or DC kind of way,
like Marvel and DC making money off
of their superheroes,
treating them like individual brands.
but the biggest problem in the boys
universe is that the vast majority
of all compound superheroes are total
dirtbags, only care about themselves in.
In some cases, they're flat out
evil, that are more benign than others.
Like some are just general perverts,
like translucent in the sun.
Maverick.
No kink shaming here, but he is an extra
special kind of degenerate.
we'll get to that in a second.
so Vought had Cardoza experimenting
on the superhero
kids underneath the school,
using the school
as a glorified testing pool to pick from
That's why they hid it under the school.
Remember,
the school was created the 1960s.
So the idea is that Vought
has been using the school since the 1960s
to experiment on kids
as much as they needed to doo.
Basically find better ways
to make money off of superheroes, either
refine compound, be or create
other things based on compound B powers
but it sounds like the actual virus
they want to use to control
superheroes is relatively new
to like the last ten, maybe 15 years.
Like Stan Agar probably always wanted
a way to control superheroes,
but Doctor
Cardoza was hired to develop it,
and he's not there, although he couldn't
have been working on it
for like more than ten
or 15 years at most.
it really didn't become a problem
for Stan Edgar and Vought until Homelander
was created, because most Compound
V superheroes aren't that powerful.
Like you could kill most Compound
V superheroes.
one of the few exceptions
to that on the TV show right now on Gen V
is the Sam character like they're saying
that he's about as powerful as Queen,
maybe not as powerful as Homelander,
but still one of the most powerful
superheroes in the world right now.
strong enough that they couldn't
just kill him in the old fashioned way
if they wanted,
like they had to put him in cryo.
Kind of like Jensen, Ackles, soldier boy.
and you have people like Homelander
who they're not able to control
because he is so powerful.
but all them all compounded superheroes
homelander included have compound
V flowing through them,
some of them more than others
like Homelander has more compound V in him
than any other superhero,
which is what makes him more powerful
than any other superhero.
one of those small vials of Compound V
is almost like hundreds
of millions of dollars.
So you have to imagine that they spent
billions and billions of dollars
creating homelander typically in the boys
universe, the more compound V you're
given, the more powerful you wind up
becoming if you survive the comp heavy.
But it's so volatile
the most people who wind up taking
it wind up getting popped like balloons.
but if they could develop
a biological agent
that would allow them to neutralize
or control the compound B
in superheroes bodies,
it would make them way easier to control.
So you basically, like, turn off
homelander powers according to Dr.
Cardoza, he now thinks that
Marie is a much better test subject
because of the way
her blood bending powers work.
That's because of her ability
to affect blood on a molecular level.
so he wants to use her to refine the virus
and make it more effective way,
way faster.
The timeline he's talking about
makes it sound like it would be ready
in time for the boys Season four,
which I think
might be why they're connecting the Gen
V show to the boys.
this that these episodes
would like directly set up season four so
might have something to do with Avar
creating the superhero deterrent.
I think it's mostly because of Homelander
getting so out of control
and what he's doing right now.
But they would be creating
something like this no matter what.
Like Vought would always want to control,
compound, be superheroes,
even if they weren't nearly as powerful
as Homelander. but.
Now that Homelander is gone,
like full blown crazy pants,
they spend their time line up like, okay,
we need to find some way to control him
way faster in.
It's still going to be a while before
Ryan is big enough in his powers
develop enough to become that deterrent
if it wasn't obvious,
like you can kind of tell
just looking at people that weren't there.
But everyone at Vought
basically is afraid of Homelander
and wants to get rid of him
like they don't want
anything to do with him,
but they're kind of forced
to deal with him because he is so powerful
But this also extends
to pretty much all other superheroes.
Like everyone agrees
that all superheroes are kind of dirtbags.
Even Stan Edgar told Homelander that much
that Val was planning to phase out
Compound V superheroes
and completely get out of that business.
that was what they called the glorious
five year plan.
Stan Edgar was going to get them
into the pharmaceutical business,
turned the company into more of a core
pharmaceutical company and just sell
the temporary compounds to the government
Because it was way more profitable.
There wasn't all the collateral damage
that comes with creating comp
happy superheroes
because they cause so much damage.
They also create a ton of headaches
to deal with,
but Stan Edgar would be behind
all of this stuff happening in the woods,
this superhero deterrent
that they're creating.
He also made the deal with Butcher
over the Ryan character
because they both agreed
that Ryan would be the best deterrent
that they had available to them
for Homelander someday, should
Homelander continue to get out of line.
Theoretically, Ryan,
because he's his son, should become
powerful enough to stop Homelander
That's more of like an end game
kind of moment for the boys main series,
like Superboy versus Superman.
actual opening scene of the episode.
Those everyone's slowly
coming to days later without realizing
Cate Mind controlled them this whole time.
So they forget
about everything that happened
and just leave the scene immediately
before the local police
showed up, causing
more problems for Vaughn,
basically allowing Vought to clean up
the problem before anybody found out.
they revealed that
she's been doing this for a long time
now, basically covering their tracks
that they can experiment on.
Sam, this whole time, like,
she'd been wiping Golden Boy's
memory on the regular
because he kept remembering about Sam.
So every time he did,
he tried to save him,
and Cate would have to wipe his mind again
so that you forget
There are a bunch of jokes about them
waking up at the party house with
superhero kids is getting their super
freak on with their superpowers.
The house belongs to Dusty,
whose powers include decelerated aging
so that he still looks like a little kid,
even though he's in his late twenties.
we find out the translucent sun
Maverick is into pretty much all manner
of freaky stuff like he does pretty much
anything you could possibly imagine.
His lama is named Sloan
who he's in a relationship with, but
I don't know if it's an actual lama,
like a regular animal
or if it's compound B superhero.
They just looks like a lama
or can take lama form.
this a superhero with scales.
She looks kind of like a mermaid.
Like this seems like her mermaid tail.
there's a fire breather.
They find Marine and Jordan
in Dusty's room.
There are posters of the seven on the wall
behind them, like this is Starlight
Queen Mab Homelander, Black Noir.
There's a poster for a movie
that A-Train made called Rapid Transit
generally all over the college,
like all over everyone's rooms.
There's all kinds of posters
and references to the seven characters
and like the fake in universe movies
and products that they sell,
couple of funny moments of them
finding out about all the fluid
leaking through the floor
below, like, man, that is gross
but as crazy as this seems
within the world of the boys, this is like
standard fare like a normal weekend
for compounded superheroes.
They're all like this.
most of the house parties that I went to
when I was in college were relatively tame
by comparison.
But I went to like a much smaller school.
The town was small,
the houses were close together,
so you can get to crazy without the police
showing up to complain about the noise.
that's always the funny thing.
Like as much crazy stuff
as you see going on in this house here.
Usually when people get in trouble
for house
parties, it's just because of the noise,
not because of any of the other stuff
that they're doing.
AMA winds up passing out in the pool
still in giant man form.
The upside, though,
is that all her social media posts
about her went viral, making her super
popular on social media, shooting her up.
The rankings app bought the only
real value that the ranking system has.
There is a sort of
like a professional sports
kind of draft situation
where the top ranked student has a chance
to make it onto the seven in the upper
ranks can also make it onto other board
sponsored superhero teams,
potentially earning way more money.
you notice behind her,
there's like a random road sign.
I wonder where that came from.
generally the damage around the pool
like around the house in general
seems pretty normal
to an actual college party
pretty average in terms of debauchery,
with a few exceptions.
when they're panning around the rooms,
there are a couple cups
from dawn of the Seven, the Boys
Universe version of the Justice League.
Snyder cut in Avengers Endgame.
It was kind of a parody of both things
from Marvel in DC, like the Justice
League of it all, and Then the endgame
part of the parody was more of the girls
get it done stuff.
There's a poster for girls, Get it done
later in the episode to Remember
there was P.J. Byrne's character,
the directed Dawn of the Seven.
He got into trouble
with Vought for being a degenerate
and then got punished by them
by putting him in director's
jail at the school,
forcing him to teach classes
where it seems like he's going to continue
to get himself into trouble,
trying to get it on with his students.
like I said,
pretty much everybody in the boys
universe is generally a terrible person.
Notice Cate is drinking
from a can of turbo rush Adrian's drink
that Andre had to do a sponsorship video
for making fun of how terrible it tastes.
This is like their way of telling everyone
without actually
telling them
that something was up with Cate.
Like, there's no way that a normal person
would actually be drinking
Turbo rush willingly.
She has to be wrong.
Something about her is just wrong.
there's another loose
cut for Donna, the seven near Andre.
There's generally a bunch of dawn of the
seven posters in cups all over the place
There's a ton of posters and lifesize
cutouts of Starlite wearing her super
slutty version of the costume
that they made her wear during season one.
that was part of her
whole storyline in season one.
Like she wanted to wear
the normal version of her costume.
But I was like, No, no, no.
The slutty version will test way higher.
Wear that Then she got into trouble
and they forced her to start
wearing the more revealing costume.
they reveal Emma's mother forbid
her from ever going to full giant man size
because of an event
that she calls the Buster Beaver incident.
they implied that
it was something sexual in nature,
but it was public
because she says you can Google it
like it is
general public knowledge on the Internet.
So it's something that happened in public,
pretty much everything that happens
damned like every terrible thing
that's happened to her
has something to do with her sexuality
in some way Sam reveals that he found them
because he use his super sense of smell
to pick up on Emma's puke,
which is gross but useful.
there's a lot of down the boys universe.
Like your power is gross, but
it's also very useful at the same time.
But because of Cate's mind.
White Neither of them remembered Sam
or anything that Emma did with him.
It's only
seeing the shirt later of the drive,
and that makes her think that
he was telling the truth about everything.
They're couple jokes about Marie's powers,
giving her the ability to know women's
bodies, cycles, like I said.
GROSS But useful powers.
Notice the rando in the background
just passed out on the couch.
Like, this is like the weird party house
where people
are just passed out on the lawn like, it's
no big deal.
then pretty much everything
that Cate says to them when they all start
talking about losing
their memories is just a cover for her.
Knowing the truth, blaming
everything on Rufus
it sounds like what Cate actually did
is the in the moment
like when they were all fighting
Sam before things got even crazier,
she used this area of effect
to basically tell them to go party
for a couple of days
because the way she explained her powers
earlier on the show,
they're super powerful
and potentially she could affect someone
for their entire life.
really good example
is that when she was a kid,
she accidentally told her brother
to never come back
and he literally never came back.
No one ever found him up to present day.
So that's why she probably only told
all the kids in the Scooby Gang
to go party for a couple days.
And that's where they woke up,
so to speak, After a couple of days,
dusty walks up.
He's wearing a Berserk manga T-shirt.
He is also a man of culture.
I see good taste in manga.
If you haven't read Bazaar,
be sure to check it out is probably
one of the greatest mangas of all time.
The anime movies are solid,
but the anime series that they did
for it, like the sequel to the anime
movies, was generally pretty rough.
So you can avoid that
just stick to the manga.
they get a little technical too.
With the way Cate explains the powers,
the mind wiping.
The whole idea is that Rufus
couldn't have done it
because his powers require him
to be very close.
Very close
range in Cate has area of effect powers,
which is why she could affect
the entire group.
At the same time
that's also why Tek
Knight told her not to take her gloves off
because it has something to do
with covering her hands
and blocking her abilities.
They don't fully explain that part of it.
but she didn't need to touch Tek Knight
in order to affect him
like its area of effect.
She could have affected him from across
the room.
Rufus is played
by Alexander Calver from Supernatural.
He became the new God
at the end of that series.
It's funny to see him be
this degenerate character on The Boys Now.
They kind of did that with Jensen
Ackles too.
Like he went
from being a pretty good character
on Supernatural
to being an absolute dirtbag on the boys
does probably one of the reasons
why he chose to do the role, like,
he gets to have a little bit of fun
and play a character
that he normally wouldn't play.
there's a huge connection between the boys
in Supernatural, just in general.
The show runner of the boys
was the creator of the Supernatural show.
So that's why you
see so many of the supernatural actors
showing up on the boys like Robert Singer,
Jensen, Ackles, Jeffrey Dean Morgan
is going to be on the Boys season four.
Now we just need Jared Padalecki
to show up at some point.
you can let me know in the comments
who you think
Jared Padalecki should play on the boys.
Maybe like a boys Season five cameo scene,
They explained that Rufus is junk
has still been blown
to smithereens, literally,
but apparently he's not in pain.
So I'm assuming that Vought gave him
some kind of healing and pain treatment
to cope.
I think, though, he has to live
the rest of his life with no junk R.I.P.
to his little dude. But he had a coming.
like I said, even though
Rufus was exonerated in the episode,
like he had nothing to do
with wiping their minds that way.
He's still a terrible, a terrible person.
the same is true for Cate,
who reveals that Rufus also abused her.
So even though
she was the victim of abuse,
she herself has been doing very evil
things in present day.
So like I said, nobody on
the boys is truly good or truly bad.
Everybody is just like a little bit
terrible.
some people like Stormfront
are a lot terrible though. Dr.
Cardoza says that Marie is way
more powerful than she realizes.
That's common
for most compound B superheroes.
most of them don't really understand
how their powers work
or ever take the time to really learn
how to use them to their fullest extent.
Marie's powers are basically
like a combination of blood bending
from Avatar, The Last Airbender, in Venom
and Carnage, symbiote like abilities.
she can control people using their blood
and controlled their blood.
Kind of like finger puppeteer people.
Avatar,
The Last Airbender, blood bending style.
she can also go full venom or carnage
forming it into weapons
or armor projectiles
using it like webbing, Spider-Man style.
She does that a couple of times
during the series too,
using her blood like webbing.
maybe by the end of the series,
she'll come more
fully into her power,
learn more about it, and go full carnage.
the only thing keeping them
from experimenting on her right now,
speeding up their timeline,
is being so high on Watts rankings.
MOSLEY There's so much attention on her.
If she were to disappear all of a sudden,
it would cause more problems for Vought.
So is this like a temporary
restraining order on going after
That'll probably change
by the end of the series.
we meet another shapeshifting superhero
when they go after Rufus Andre tries
to go full magneto on him until Rufus
mind controls him to go to a burger.
so it's kind of like evil.
Professor X against Magneto, X-Men style,
most of the superhero references on Gen V
so far are leaning more heavily
towards the X-Men side of things.
lot of burger is basically like the Boys
Universe version of Big Belly Burger
inside the DC Universe.
They did a campaign
before the series came out
where they would like send
specially branded VADA burger
like regular hamburgers branded as Vought
a burger to a bunch of different people.
sometimes they'll do pop up restaurants
at places like Comic-Con.
later you notice
Rufus is Cup has homelander on it.
then Sam has another puppet hallucination.
When he's attacked by Vought
soldiers destroying them all
like a muppet massacre.
They also use the puppet stuff
to go way over the top in a way
that would be way harder
to do in actual live action.
basically going for homelander
on all the guards, He also winds up
seeing a puppet version of Emma.
Maybe we'll see Puppet versions
of some of the other characters too.
The Marie finds what looks like a tracker
or a failsafe device
that Vought has put
Insider is not exactly clear what it is.
It looks like
it might be like a small smart device
that they can use as a deterrent
in case they want to kill her quickly.
or might be one of the early prototypes
for the control device that they're trying
to create using that superhero virus.
But it's not clear
if Vought put those inside the Scooby Gang
after what happened with Sam recently,
or if they put those inside
all the students
when they come to the school,
the couple more messed up funny moments
with Maverick
revealing more of his degeneracy
like he loves hiding in both girls and
boys showers just as much as the other.
Just like his father Translucent,
who used to hide in women's bathrooms.
like father, like son
there are a bunch of posters
for the seven in other characters
along the hallway too.
Like there's crimson counters
here as well.
And also there's a turbo rush
vending machine warning
Do not drink from the turbo rush
vending machine.
Not because
Vought is trying to poison you,
but because you might accidentally
get poisoned because it's so terrible.
we get a brief scene
between Cate in the scene where they try
to explain a little bit more
why Cate has been doing this.
She believes falsely
that she is trying to protect her friends.
Like if she doesn't do this,
then Vought will kill all of her friends.
basically the dean is trying
to brainwash her into wanting to help
Vought saying whatever
she needs to say to get her to do this.
So you think this has been trying
to set Cate up for a redemption arc
during the series,
like something bad is going to happen,
Nikki, Because what is abusing her
the same way they're abusing
everyone else, they're making her believe
that she's doing the right thing,
even though she's doing terrible stuff.
when Emma goes to the Burger Shack.
As she goes inside, Zoomin enhanced
on these articles in the newspapers.
You can see an article about Butcher
saying that the manhunt for him continues.
This seems relatively recent to the boys.
There's there a couple other articles here
referencing other people from the boys
series as well.
Cate and Andre
watch old episodes of Messina's TV show.
That was Haley Joel
Osment character from season one.
The joke was he grew up as a child star
with compound beat powers
in the world of the boys.
But in real life,
he was also a child star.
the style, the lettering on the TV show
seems like a reference to law
and order, like the TV show
was from the nineties the girls go to
Rufus is He's also watching those same
old episodes of Messina's TV show.
So maybe he's just like a really popular
old TV show around campus.
Rufus also reveals that he works
at the Dean's office,
so maybe they'll use that
to their advantage in future episodes.
There are a couple more references to
the seven characters around this room too.
Like there's a poster for Black Noir,
there's that Girls Get it done poster
there's another poster
for In a Black Noir's movies that he made,
Andre almost winds up
killing Rufus with his magneto powers
until Cate shows up and confesses
to everything as he slowly remembers
everything from the last several days.
they cut to black.
But in next week's episode,
the trailer makes it seem like something
weird or terrible is going to be happening
to the Cate character in
maybe they're setting her up
for a redemption arc
and the kids
will eventually have to save her too.
But it's only going to get crazier
before it starts to get better.
there's also a weird teaser
for Jensen Ackles Soldier Boy Character.
We knew that he was going to cameo
during the series.
At some point it seems like
he's coming back during episode six.
So if he spotted any other Easter eggs
in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them
below in the comments in post
all your predictions for episode six.
What do you think that Jensen Ackles
Soldier Boy is going to be doing?
Unless they pull him out of cryo storage.
He's still in cryo deep freeze right now.
So this could be a hallucination
or it could have something
to do with Cate's powers.
Like somebody could be mind
controlling people to hallucinate.
Soldier Boy
but it is
brand new footage of Jensen Ackles
who came back to film
new scenes to do this
they'll be more cameos from other big boys
characters like other people
from the seven in future episodes too.
Like we'll probably eventually
see Homelander show up on the show.
My Episode 6 video will post next week
after they release it
and there's supposed to be
a new invincible Season 2
trailer video this weekend.
Probably one of the other best
new superhero series next to the boys.
I'll be doing weekly episode videos
for that when it premieres in November,
but that's not going to be
for a couple more weeks.
click Here for my full Loki Season 2
Episode 1 Video
and click Here for all my Boys
Gen V Episodes
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!